this is curtin davina reading for kevin
kenizevic
with 2016's monster hunter stories for
the 3ds capcom transformed its real-time
strategy monster hunting series
into something dramatically different a
colorful
turn-based monster collecting rpg
despite the stark change in tone and
gameplay
stories offered a new perspective on the
monster hunter universe
making it an enjoyable alternative to
the mainline series
its follow-up monster hunter stories 2
wings of ruin very much follows
the template that the original 3ds game
set and despite some repetitive elements
it's another solid spinoff for the
[Music]
franchise
like its predecessor monster hunter
stories 2 trades monster slaying
for monster collecting rather than
casting you in the role of a hunter the
game puts you in the boots of a fledging
writer
someone who is able to form bonds with
monsters and fight alongside them while
you'll still need to hunt down plenty of
monsters during your journey
you'll spend most of your time exploring
dens and collecting new
monster companions that you can raise
and take into battle
this makes monster hunter stories 2
closer to pokemon than to a traditional
monster hunter title but the game plays
out much differently
than nintendo's monster catching series
foremost is the way you collect monsters
rather than taming wild ones you obtain
new monsters by entering monster dens
and gathering their eggs these crop up
randomly each time you set out into the
overworld and primarily come in
two varieties standard dens and golden
rare dens that typically obtain better
eggs
regardless of their type the dens
themselves are all rudimentary in terms
of their layouts
beyond some occasional branching
pathways which usually just lead to
optional treasures
there are no real environmental puzzles
to solve
so they're not particularly compelling
to explore on their own
despite this the allure of discovering
new kinds of eggs
never grows old and makes trekking
through dens
worthwhile especially as you progress
through the story
and begin encountering cooler monsters
in addition to regular monster duns
each major area in the game also
features a handful of larger dungeons
called
everdads these are much more
labyrinth-like than standard dens and
house some unique treasures such as
rare eggs and bottle caps which can be
exchanged for special items and upgrades
like
increased storage space for your
monsters these upgrades make bottle caps
among the most
valuable commodities in the game but
they're not as satisfying to find
like regular dens aberdens don't offer
much variety so they end up feeling
samey and
aren't all enjoyable to navigate and no
thanks to their whining pathways you'll
often
hit multiple dead ends before you
eventually locate the monster nest which
makes everton's more of a chore to
explore than regular dents
after you've obtained an egg you can
take it back to the stables and hatch a
new monster
depending on the egg's rarity and weight
the monster you obtain will boast
different genes which
determines what skills and attacks it
will be able to use during the battle
these genes are crucial if you hope to
get the most out of your monstem and
they become a sort of
mini-game unto themselves if you align
three jeans of the same color you'll
achieve a bingo
bonus which will power up your mazda
even further you can also pass genes
between monsters through a process
called
rite of channeling this offers a
pleasing amount of flexibility in
customizing your monste's skills and
feels rewarding to devise
new combinations
your monsies primarily come in use in
battle unlike the mainline series
encounters and monster hunter stories
too
are turn-based while there are elemental
weaknesses and advantages to consider
battles revolve around three different
types of attacks
power speed and technical each type has
an advantage
over another speed bests power power
beats technical
and technical overcome speed the crux of
the battles then
become figuring out which type of attack
the enemy monster will use
and swapping in the right monster to
counter it it's a simple yet
satisfying system and the game keeps it
fresh by introducing new kinds of
monsters with different attack patterns
the weapons you use are also crucial to
combat
weapons like monsters fall into three
varieties
slash pierce and blunt which lends
itself an additional layer of strategy
different parts of a monster are
susceptible to a particular type of
weapon
so you'll need to swap out weapons
frequently during the course of a battle
and target specific parts to deal the
most damage
attack apart enough times and you will
eventually break it causing the monster
to drop
a material and topple over while a
monster is prone on the ground each
attack will deal critical
damage and you can even halt some
monsters from unleashing their strongest
attacks
by breaking a specific part of their
body these wrinkles make battles feel
consistently enjoyable
and the game boasts some nice quality of
life features such as the ability to
fast forward animations and even
end battles against lower level foes
immediately to mitigate the grind
beyond their in-battle abilities each
monster can also perform a certain
action while you ride them out in the
field
which will help you reach some otherwise
inaccessible areas
the yeon kudku for instance can smash
rocks that are blocking the path
however these writing actions are
underutilized during the maid adventure
which is disappointing
rather than opening up new paths to
explore these skills are typically used
to reach
out of the way treasure chests whose
contents are
often underwhelming as a result the
skills used in the field are
largely unnecessary and don't really add
anything to the experience
the weakest element in monster hunter
stories 2 is
ironically its story while the narrative
is certainly more involved than a
traditional monster hunter game
it largely stays within jrpg tropes and
is predictable
as a result
the story also skews toward a younger
audience as evidenced by
navarro your cartoonish wise cracking
feline companion
from here on out we're gonna be partners
and i'll do it all totally free of
charge
since your avatar never speaks navarro
takes up most of the dialogue
and he frequently straddles the line
between cute and
annoying that said the story does broach
some themes that the mainline series
never explores such as the seemingly
incompatible world views
of hunters and writers and it's filled
with humorous
and touching moments overall monster
hunter stories 2
wings of ruin is an enjoyable monster
hunter spin-off and an all-around
solid jrpg particularly if you enjoy
games like pokemon while the title
retains some of the series hallmark
elements
its emphasis on monster collecting and
its fun turn based battle system
make it a different experience than
monster hunter rise one
that even those who've struggled to get
into the proper monster hunter series
can enjoy
[Music]
you